I love your character Jared but he gets
its rough because the character gets
insulted a lot yeah and by the other
characters and they write really mean
insults for Jared sure but they're about
his physical appearance and that's you
when I'm wondering does it ever get
confusing like do you ever get your
feelings hurt by what the other
characters are saying about your no
because I get it I've seen myself like I
get it I mean I don't think I'm like a
hideous monster yeah you're a very
good-looking fellow I think you're very
good once we're gonna know like like I
get it like I'm long and white and I
have my face bends and strange ways and
I I remember like in the first face
bends in stream I mean I don't mind I'm
okay but but the the early the first
episode I think there was a insult where
they say or I say my uncle used to say I
looked like a virgin who starved himself
to death or another one was you look
like the poster boy for the gay
morticians Union I'm like yeah checks
out yeah
what's all for a good cause it's all for
a good guy it's for good guys
you